[Music]
you are listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum i
hope you're uh having a lovely day
maybe you're in the car right now just
uh hearing my soothing voice
and ryan's terrible special effects
special effects which is room
he's feisty today ryan ryan's feisty
real
um here it comes this segment mental
health checking how you doing
how are you ryan oh i'm all right i went
on a run and that helped
well good you're starting to do things
yeah it's not that you're not doing
things you're constantly working but
it's doing things for yourself
yeah that the odd thing i have a friend
who's in town is that simple no that's a
good thing
oh you get out of the house i get out of
the house and actually and play music
this is my
my friend of known since high school i
play music together you play music
together oh yeah you did an album with
him yeah
yeah i like that yeah you could listen
to that tell them where to get that you
go to or we're called matakanis
spell it m-a-t-a-c-a-n-e-s
yeah take a listen it's really good
there's one song in particular i liked
it's on spotify what's the song i liked
probably suckered in suckered in yeah
that's the one i wrote
yep there you go um take a listen ryan's
a talented talented guy
and uh he's not only talented at uh
editing but uh a lot of other things
singing acting loving living
living loving and watch we're gonna get
like uh
yelled out but it's not long enough or
good enough
um thank you for listening guys um very
special guest on the podcast today if
you're here
for laura i really encourage you to
support the podcast because we have so
many great
guests and i really think you're going
to like it if you do please subscribe
please subscribe on youtube um if you're
watching it or if you want to listen on
apple or stitcher or spotify
it means the world to me and i really
believe you're going to like it um so if
you're here for laura
i hope you'll stick around maybe even
write a review but uh i won't get my
hopes up but
uh also the handles ryan what are the
handles on the social
they are at inside of you pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on facebook and
instagram
yeah that's exactly right and uh i
i read this last week but you know i i
just like this quote i don't need to get
into it but
you can't wait until life isn't hard
anymore before you decide to be happy
you can't wait until life isn't
hard anymore before you decide to be
happy i want you to think about that
because i thought about it and uh
it makes a lot of sense so you take with
it what you will
um laura really opened up today she uh
she opened up last time but this time is
different because we get to see her on
video so you get to watch the beautiful
laura
and uh she was very articulate she was
open
honest and forthcoming and all that
stuff and uh
i really appreciated this interview so
let's not even wait around
uh before that i will tell you if you
want to join patreon uh the lovely
my patreon community it's like a family
if you don't know what it is
check it out it supports the podcast in
other ways there's tears
uh certain tiers get boxes for me every
couple of months and little notes from
me
they'll also get to ask the guest
questions on talking segments with
the guest
they get to ask me questions on q a with
rosenbaum every month
um they get bonus episode bonus material
disc certain discounts just lots of
stuff it's called patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
you can go to patreon.com
society if you want to join become my
patreon i'll message you right after
and uh also the inside you store tons of
great stuff from lex luthor to inside
you stuff
inside you online store and also
sunspin.com to get any band merch like
this beautiful sunspin shirt
um that's about all i have to say today
um
thank you for listening we'll uh read
off the the patrons
um at the end of the show and um thanks
for listening
and let's get inside of laura vandervort
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you were on here about uh a while ago
about a while ago two years ago i think
i had you on we just did audio you okay
over there you're
adjusting i'm fine you are yes first of
all put me in a corner
i know you're well nobody puts baby in
the corner
guys you know what that's from i hope
you know that's from you shouldn't be
listening to this podcast if you don't
know that trump's from uh
dirty dancing that's right take me a
second do you notice i know you're a big
horror fan like me and that's why we get
along so well did you notice all the
posters are horror
of course which movies have you seen
have you seen fright night evil dead uh
i i don't i haven't seen a lot of the
like more classic ones i'm gonna have to
write you a list
yeah i feel like you did at one point
obviously dracula yes
aliens the thing yes okay returning
return of the living dead
no okay not super into the zombie
do you like the psychological thriller
yeah you like that which is one that i
just shot
you what was it called black okay first
of all
i say beg i'm canadian big like a bag
it's called black bag not black bag
right but
i have to say that word in every scene
so they they tell you hey you said beg
again no i just consciously like before
i say the word say bad
bad bag but you didn't for this
interview that's what you said
because that doesn't matter i'm not
being paid my podcast doesn't matter
um so you did a horror movie it's a
psychological thriller
yeah and it's a little indie i remember
talking to you about this so you it's
great because you do these projects like
handmaid's tale and um you know
supergirl and all these guest stars and
whatever blah blah blah but you make a
little money but on the independent
films you probably don't make much money
none none
whatsoever but well you make something
they have to pay you right
enough enough to get by and pay your
bills yeah the per diem also helps but
uh what do you get for per diem 150
bucks 65.
65 a day yeah that's pretty good well
not on your days off because 65.
but i'll take it i'm trying to build a
fence so you're trying to build the
fence at your house yeah
okay i got my first house but um is this
a good movie because let me tell you
something i am
horrified for lack of a better word
because i've been watching a lot of
horror movies and you could see some of
my tweets i did a tweet that said dear
horror
what what happened where are you what
happened to you well this isn't horror
this is like
this is a thriller this is about two
women whose lives kind of collide
due to unforeseen circumstances and all
i can give anything away
it's it's an indie film the script was
great um
and i haven't seen two female leads in a
while that have written
have been written so well i mean this
was it written by a woman woman
it was originally written by a man
rewritten by a woman ah go
figure right there you go angela yeah
and uh like
this is the first time i've done a film
where it's basically a play i mean i was
doing 12 pages a day just like monologue
are you
so you're good with dialogue now i mean
you've always been pretty good with that
yeah if it's well written it's it's
completely easy to memorize right it
just flows but
it's the ones that aren't that are
trouble um you also
my my dog irv passed as you know and it
was very i want to say thank you because
you sent me a nice message
and it was really sweet and it was uh i
know you you made me a t-shirt with
herb's face on it once i did remember
that
yes so that was very kind um you know
ryan
um laura you look scared ryan's never on
the air i'm gonna put him on the air
you know she's canadian can you give me
three canadian uh words
uh took correct it's a hat
beanie yes uh uh poutine
it's not really a canadian word routine
that sounds good but
you know what 15 is what is that you
know what that is it's fries with gravy
and cheese curds oh that's called
poutine yeah i've
can you name three provinces in canada
did you know this was gonna happen uh
yeah uh british columbia alberta and uh
let's see saskatchewan moose jaw
saskatchewan
that's correct um do you find it
unnerving when you get a job in canada
that they hire you because they know
they could pay you a lot less
of course when is that going to stop
they hire you for u.s productions that
are filming in canada and yet they pay
you canadian rates
because you're from canada well yeah i
mean some you can get sag deals like
sig like smallville i would say
sag right so they gave you a better deal
right um so you can try to negotiate
that but yeah if they're looking for a
tax write-off
i mean the thing is in canada we have a
lot of really talented crew and cast
and and writers directors but they the
american shows come in and take
over and then we really only get cast
for
small guest stars which is fine like we
it's not fine
but we all want to work and i think
canadians are just like working actors
we don't
obviously we care about the craft but we
just like to consistently work like i'll
do a big show like handmaids or
a movie like jigsaw or whatever and then
i'll also do tiny
films that feed my soul because the big
ones don't
you seem very um i don't know you have a
good energy about you today
i'm tired it's not maybe maybe you're
tired i don't know what it is but
not that the last time because last time
was a great interview but this time you
just i don't know you feel
more together maybe yeah yeah
um do you think it's because you well
you're not old don't get into age with
me
okay don't get into age things with guys
that are people that are older than you
but i know you moved back home you got
kind of tired of the l.a scene kind of
tired of hollywood maybe tired of dating
which we could of course talk about but
you move
back home you live near your folks you
live near your sister yeah
currently with my sister you live with
your sister
so what happened i just i don't know
what i would do
just open okay well first of all i love
my family so it's like not a big deal i
love my family
um i was shooting a show in toronto
when the pandemic hit and
um my sister has two kids and her
husband
so i went to live with them because i
someone broke my heart i had a like
really bad breakup i lost the house in
toronto
kind of didn't have anywhere to go so i
moved in with her for what i thought
would be like two weeks for this weird
pandemic thing to help with the kids
like i did
homeschooling and all of that four
months later
i was still homeschooling and um luckily
they got a sitter eventually but
i'm still living there i bought a house
it's being demoed right now okay so
you're not gonna
continue i'm just going back for like
three more months until my house
is ready i think we have similarities i
think that you know
we like everyone out there i hate saying
this but we
we all want to be happy and sometimes it
gets
convoluted what we think happiness is
right so
we don't look at our lives we forget
that we had success or have success or
what we're doing and we're you know
all these great things are happening in
our life and we the attention is
um gets kind of put in a place where
we're focusing on other people's success
and
we're comparing it to ours and then it
looks as though like
even like your sister she has two kids
she's married
and i know you so i know you think
that's success
that's happiness why can't i have that
right we look at other people
i have friends that are married and have
kids and go to school and i
see you know i'm sometimes alone and i'm
like you know wow i'm 48 years
old and do you ever i mean you're not as
old as i am but
do you think sometimes you're chasing
the wrong things that you think
suddenly that the same things that
you're after
no matter because we're insatiable we
get a job and we feel good for i got a
job i'm acting and i'm acting and then
that kind of
it goes away yeah so it's not
sustainable so
maybe what my grandmother and other
people have been trying to tell me for a
long time is
have a family you can still do all the
other things but it fills the void in
between
so do you think that your sister do you
look up to her like god i wish i had
your life
um i i there's portions of it she's
gonna laugh um
well sarah's a she's a great woman she's
a great mom she's a badass like right
now she's handling my reno's
basically for me she's got a job two
kids a husband
like i can't keep up with her everything
is scheduled everything is organized i
admire that
i and and she's so smart i am
not that kind of smart uh i do this to
myself all the time ryan knows it i
constantly say
i'm just not that smart i'm not then
people but there's different versions
constantly like
yeah like you know there's street smart
there's book smart there's common sense
smart
i don't know where i lie i don't know
where you lie either
you're probably a little of everything
ryan how would you describe me
well kind of smart yeah what kind of
smart am i
you're like uh oh god oh great
i don't know i feel like i feel like
he's like street smart
but also i wouldn't say book smart i
think you're just intellectually
you're not an idiot no
i think you use the skills you have and
and use them wisely
i know how to use my skills to the best
of their abilities
yeah you've parlayed what you're good at
into
i'm not going to nominate you for
jeopardy but i'm also not going to i do
alright in jeopardy i'm also not going
to take you to like you know
to a drug deal either you're like
somewhere in between yeah the street
smart and
you're you're medium smart a medium
smart you're medium smart
i think a lot of us are medium smart i
think that's okay i think you're smarter
than that i think ryan's naturally
i think ryan's caught a lot of common
sense and
but this isn't about him no um but but
but happiness is like that's what i'm
always wondering i'm always thinking
am i doing everything wrong and how long
am i going to chase this because you
know i've talked to people who
don't get started chasing fame because
that's a dead end road yeah don't start
chasing fame and start changing i need
more followers because you look online
sometimes and you're like
i jus yeah it's never enough right you
look online you're like i just made the
funniest video
and i got fifteen thousand views or
whatever the it is
you know what this all means nothing in
the real world you can't
no you can't die with those views no no
it doesn't leave a legacy you a family
does
what you do who does what i'm saying is
i look at that and then all of a sudden
i saw i see somebody who has like three
million followers
and 300 000 people like to pose of them
doing a yoga pose
like 300 000 people like this
yoga pose you got to know your fan base
no it's not that it's like i don't have
that meant as many fans so what i'm
saying is
you start to compare i'm like what are
you doing you you made 15 000 people
happy with your post
what are you what are you comparing
yourself that's what i do a lot
i compare and i always talk about don't
compare but i think we compare ourselves
and we're like
if we just we're in the moment do you do
that
which part and why are you yelling well
uh do you do you tend to post something
and then go oh look i got this many
likes i got this moment i'm i'm human
i'm in an industry where the social
media
is necessary in fact i just worked with
an actress
who makes a lovely profit on
you know catering her social media to
branding
and she was teaching me a little bit for
me it's a tool
of course there's days where you're
feeling like about yourself and
you're like no you know you look at your
posts and how many people commented and
what's negative
but i really just try to view it as a
business i use it as a tool to promote
my work
to talk about products i like to talk
about eco-friendly does it make you
happy though do you see a rise in
happiness
tons of people like it and then also no
one likes it so you're like
oh it's placebo of course which is why i
wrote my film which is about that really
what's it called
uh my soul to take it's the one i
directed
yeah so you're doing a lot of stuff now
do you tend to do a lot of stuff because
you really love doing it you want to do
it or do you think there's part of it
that you want to prove yourself
100 both 100 percent both yeah as a
woman
um i've been acting since i was 12
i've always been an actress i don't
think i'm a stellar actress
i think i'm a working actor and so i
want to show that i can do other things
so there's definitely a prove yourself
part to writing and directing and i've
been producing but also i really enjoyed
it like i
enjoy i enjoy the control um my soul to
take looks beautiful i had crew from
like
i'll send you a link from canada my
composer was stellar like it was a lot
of women
um but you just said something a few
minutes ago
you said i don't think of myself as a
stellar actress is that true
do you look at yourself and say i know
what i'm good i think i'm good
you think you're good i think i'm good
do you know you're good and i'm getting
better
yeah yeah i i but you don't think you're
great you don't think you're stellar
no i think i'm i'm i'm good that's hard
to say it's hard to
somebody said are you a great actor i'm
not gonna compare myself to
you know meryl streep i think i'm a
working actor who can do a good job
right you know that's why i get cast in
and shows that i do
because i can bring it and and leave
and you know like handmaids
i don't i haven't seen that yet but i
hear that you have a it's a fantastic
role
can i spoil it yeah i mean if you
haven't watched it yet just you know
just mute the next few minutes but
supposedly you you poison all these men
while they're having this big party and
you just kill them all
all the commanders yeah i my friend alex
who listens to the podcast said
she's really great in it thanks yeah she
said that
i think just an aside as i'm getting
older i'm like sitting into things more
and i'm finding it much quicker
you know back on smallville i'd be like
give me the tear stick
i need like an hour i need to look at
videos of dogs being put down like i i
need to do that
and now it's like okay just let me know
when we're rolling give me a minute
and then like i know where it is now
right i feel comfortable in it like
i i've experienced life for 36 years
and i want to share this i'm always on
edge
i feel like i'm always i have to like my
whole life's been i have to be great i
have to be great at this i have to come
through i have to show them that i'm
great i can't
i have to know my lines instead i have
of course you know and that drives me up
a wall where i wish i could sit there
and say
i've settled into myself i'm fine i'm
fine
i can just do this i know what i'm doing
it's not that i don't know what i'm
doing
but i i second-guess myself a lot i
think that's normal like i still do that
the the project i just did was an indie
film
so i felt very comfortable to explore
like there wasn't really a
clock ticking we would do three takes
and i'd say to the director if you
get what you want and you have time give
me one and just tell me to play
and when i got to play i did
things that i would never have been
comfortable with when i knew they might
use the take like this was like
oh it's a throwaway take i'm gonna do
this now like i change i lay down i get
on the floor i do weird and then it
turns out being great because i
i knew i'd done my job i knew the lines
and now i can play when you get a roll
are you immediately nervous
yeah i'm like why did they cast me
they're going to fire me i hear that a
lot i hear that a lot from a lot of
actors
and then you settle in once you learn
the lines you start to get into it gotta
get a couple days in
right so give yourself a couple days to
just like you're gonna be nervous you're
gonna be this
and then you'll start to get into it
that's sort of the thing also that
project i was talking about i was
replacing an actress
four days before production which starts
rehearsals
that's hard there's that oh a second
choice thing
listen to me i've made my career being
someone's second choice
i have i have uh they have recast um
using me
in in many a role and um they're like
you know what
rosenbaum's probably available
let's get him to do it i don't i don't
mind it um
i think i got frustrated and my ego
definitely was
up there with you know i should be
getting bigger roles this is really
that's the way i thought yeah come on
just watch some of my do i really
need to audition for this come on watch
it get
cocky in my head yeah and i tell my age
and i go send them the reel what the
i mean i
send them this scene what can i do
and then i realize no matter who you are
no matter
what you're doing you got to prove
yourself and unless you're de niro
i realized that years ago and then that
you know i kind of
it makes you a little bit more what's
the word ryan it makes you feel
it makes you more well it's definitely
definitely more humble yes it's
it's humbling to think hey who the
are you dude
yeah he did some good work does some
great work but you know what if you want
to do more great work you're gonna have
to bust your ass for it like
everybody else does and that's what i
did realize
right and also just keeping those
muscles active like doing these indie
films that feel good
you know for your soul and trying new
things out i mean for for
handmaids i i booked it
i had to do three auditions
and i was two days out from my
days off starting my days on set
pandemic hit i waited seven months with
all those scenes in my head with
elizabeth
freaking the out for seven seven
months running torturing yourself yeah
yeah
and then you killed it that's what i'm
hearing but um
i was petrified i watched it i i can't
watch
but you watched yourself in handmaids i
can't watch all of it i just
how are you how did you like yourself i
thought i
did a good job
but i was elizabeth i was terrified
you know what i'm getting on a head show
see i never understood that like guest
stars
that is the hardest thing i've
never had to really experience that
you're the new kid in school
i i don't know if i could deal with just
coming on a set and everybody's like
this i hope he's knows a
lot i hope he's voting i'm just it's in
my head i'm like
i just want to you know what i mean and
then you have to just and action uh
can we replace him is it available
inside of you is brought to you by
better help ryan just got some better
help
he tried it i did it's been you know
sitting in front of my face this whole
time i figured
why why not really it can only help yeah
and you're digging it so far it's the
beginning but you're
you're you're digging it yeah so far you
figured i need a little help i need to
talk to someone when you're doing it and
let's see what this is all about let's
see what's all about and that's that's
all it takes it takes it
one step at a time one step at a time uh
throughout june inside of your podcast
is proud to join the cause of
destigmatizing therapy
it's just it's time folks we realize
that you know people need help i mean we
stress out and we bottle stuff
up and like if you're struggling with
anxiety
or having difficulty sleeping
meeting your goals if you just can't get
things done there's a lot of different
issues we have
death better help counselors can listen
and they can help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional you can start communicating
in under 48 hours did that happen for
you ryan that happened
in yeah well under 48 hours for me so
they're what they're saying what they're
preaching is what they're practicing
that might not be everyone but yeah for
me it was very good
they say they start communicating within
48 hours so i'm going to believe that
one yep
uh therapists have a broad range of
expertise that may not be locally
available in your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide log in to your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
how easy is that you can do weekly
videos phone
live chat sessions ryan you do the
videos do the video chat that's what i
do it helps me
i like to see who i'm talking to and
look if you don't like your counselor if
you're not vibing with them they'll get
you another counselor this happens this
is typical
i've gone through counselors well before
i even knew better help
and you have to get the right one that
fits your needs and uh makes you feel
comfortable
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors
if needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling ryan
would you agree with that i would
definitely agree and financial aid is
available so many people have been using
better help
that they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
give it a shot ryan gave it a shot i'm
giving it a shot
therapy is is is certainly helpful
especially in this day and age where
we're all dealing with a lot of stuff uh
you got to get it off your chest
our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
inside inside of you is brought to you
by public wreck
uh i just i got these sweatpants ryan
i've never been this comfortable
i really have never felt this
comfortable i don't even feel like
wearing underwear when i wear these
sweatpants really yeah that's how
comfortable they are and i got these
raggedy old
uh sweatpants and my friends are like
you look
you look like you're not well you look
like you're not doing well like what do
you mean
they could tell by my sweatpants like
could you could you know you're going to
a gathering can you put something
and i don't want to wear pants but with
public wreck they've got these pants
that are just the perfect length
they're more comfortable and yet they
look nicer look it's frustrating to have
to change
and put your pants on and do this but
now i can wear these all the time and i
can go anywhere with these and people
like oh it looks nice
because public wreck made some cool ass
sweatpants sweet you know what i'm
talking about i know what you're talking
about what's great about public wreck is
they make
leisure wear in waist and in seam sizes
because comfort starts
with a better fit their best-selling
all-day everyday pants are more stylish
alternatives to sweatpants
and a more comfortable alternative to
jeans multifaceted their clothing is
great for lounging at home looking sharp
for work heading to the bar
and anywhere pants should be worn sizing
that makes sense the all-day
everyday pant comes in waist and inseam
sizing so they fit
short guys tall guys and everyone in
between and i think that's pretty
magical
all the things you want in clothing made
from breathable stretchy
moisture wicking fabric you can wear
them 24
7 which i like and i will they also have
zipper pockets so no more having your
phone or wallet fall out when you sit
down and lord knows
i've had that everything comes out of my
sweatpants but not with public correct
nine different colors one for each day
of the week and then some
uh they've got incredibly comfortable
shirts
uh shorts henley's polos hoodies jackets
even golf wear and they just launched
their women's
line so now anyone listening can enjoy
public wrecks game-changing fabric
in their wardrobe these are always the
top choice
in my rotation i've never had pants fit
this well period
i wish you could put them on in fact
after this podcast ryan i'm gonna take
my pants off and i'm gonna put them on
you
oh great i'm in the process of updating
all the pants in my wardrobe to these or
at least most of them the performance
fabric is unlike any other clothing and
i love it as the world's opening back up
make sure you've got clothes that are as
flexible as your life is
public wreck rarely discounts but right
now they have an exclusive offer just
for inside of you listeners
go to public rec dot com slash iou to
receive
10 off that's public wreck
rec dot com slash iou
for 10 off you've got to try
these pants at public wreck inside of
you
is brought to you by geico
geico talk about easy talk about making
my life easy ryan i know you rent your
apartment
and uh yeah you own this house yeah and
i know that you probably pay your auto
policy
i do separate place but yeah probably
not the way to go that's exactly right
we all pay at different places we have
all these people to pay
and geico is going to make it easy for
you because they have a bundling policy
everybody knows geico
they're everywhere omnipresent and uh
they know what they're doing over there
at geico and they make it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy because we
don't have time folks we don't have time
to do a pay all these people
geico makes it easy it's geico easy go
to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you could
save it's
geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com geico
has there ever been a time when someone
wasn't kind to you as
when you were a guest star and you felt
like they were just a little um
condescending or like oh you're the
pretty guest star you
yeah yeah you definitely have felt that
and it wasn't just you feeling that
or thinking like it was you felt that it
was what i'm saying
yeah and it wasn't exactly that way it
was a show
where the lead i don't think wanted me
there
so we did all of her coverage and then
when they turned around on me she told
me her stand-in was gonna do
her lines she was gonna go home so it
was it wasn't like it was like a respect
thing it was like uh i'm not gonna say i
know you're not gonna say it was worth a
shot
yeah jeez can you imagine but i've had
other bad you know i i did it i did an
hbo show
that i left i didn't go back
and they apologized for what had
happened what happened
a little me too stuff really and
i yeah i didn't return and and and i was
like oh god they're never gonna hbo is
never gonna work with me again and it
was just that particular did you
did you say it did you mince it on
social media mention it no
it wasn't it wasn't like a direct direct
thing it was it was
anyway something made you uncomfortable
yes very uncomfortable and you said i'm
not coming back
i don't feel safe i wish i i went to my
hotel room that night and
called my agent and i was shaking um
but again it wasn't a direct thing it
was the environment
of the show and what they were doing
especially
with like sudden rewrites where you're
doing something that
wasn't scripted was not appropriate
right um
but it wasn't hbo it was that
environment
whomever was running the show was
allowing that right
so i've had different situations when
you go on a show
like supergirl right mm-hmm
if you go on a show on supergirl and you
played supergirl
that's gotta be a weird thing to say
okay i'm gonna be a guest star on a show
called supergirl when i was supergirl in
smallville
and then was that was that a fun
experience
yep it was yep
okay so we don't want to talk about this
we don't want to talk about this because
i talked to erica durants who was on
there and
you know um she said it was fine it was
fine
were the people nice some of them yeah
some of them were really nice yeah yeah
they do feel nice
yeah and some of them didn't some of
them didn't the the
character was fun i was blue and i was a
villain and it was very different
i'm parlaying i'm just like pivoting
yeah you could be pivoting you could do
it you were blue
it was blue all right uh it's it's got
to be like i don't think i could do it
like for instance
if there lex luther and then they said
hey we want you to come in to play a
character
i don't know i don't know if i'd feel
it depends my ego would say ah there's
only one
there's only one lex luthor
that's what my ego would say right
if it was a good enough role maybe i
would think differently but if i got on
set and i was people were acting a
little weird to me or something
and it's always different for guys guys
have a lot easier
women don't women it's not easy it's not
easy
always having to look great and always
having to be thin and always having to
you know it's all about your looks and
you know guys could grow a beard and
go oh i think i got an audition have you
had four beers no one gives a i
hate shaving my beard but i have to do
it all the time i hate shaving my beard
i gotta do it every day
uh yeah i have a new segment i'm i'm
calling it it's called how you doing
how you doing
this is a mental health check-in just
and it could be anything so laura how
you doing
that's such a broad question well
ultimately how you feeling how you're
for instance ryan how you doing
doing okay i'm writing notes
that's not really what i meant um
i'm i'm i'm i'm doing well
um in a much better place than the last
time i was here
yeah i just started listening to my gut
and changes everything
listening to your gut your gut always
knows doesn't it
it does and you always think oh no i
think you're wrong
how often do we date someone and your
gut says
get out yeah but you say there's just
this attraction and maybe
my gut's wrong and i'm just like well
and you end up
right where you knew you'd end up yeah
five years yep
i'm sorry was that not a personal story
huh
you but were you so you do you but do
you have a propensity
to i like this word to date actors
mostly date actors don't you um
people in the industry yeah would you
rather not why do you do that i don't
want to date anymore actors
excuse you excuse me why do you i forgot
you could hear it because of the
microphones
why do you why do you think you do that
why do you think um
honestly it's just the only people that
i meet right
also i like the energy i like
personality i like quirkiness and
you don't often get that if you're gonna
date a banker you know
and and they don't understand the
lifestyle they don't understand the
weird
things that we do as actors to prepare
you know
like i i go to dark places
places do you go how dark can you get
i don't know how to answer that well i
mean is it one of those things where
you're drinking a half a fifth of
whiskey and you're listening to mazzy
star
for 40 minutes straight and you're going
i hated i hate my life right
here
i just don't know who i am anymore i
mean what is it what happens i would say
like
50 that but it's more like red wine
um no i just i just i just
sort of separate myself from society and
like shut off for a little bit
that's i i have my you know my tools
what's the go-to if you want a good cry
and we know a lot of times we want a
good cry so we do something that would
provoke a good cry like there's a
certain song if it played
that i could cry to it which one fade
into you by mazzy star
that is a song that's that's a trigger
uh maybe sailing
christopher cross i could definitely
tear up on that one was it big world
by uh oh god you know you're probably
choose your fears
is it yours mad world mad world mad
world that's one that i always listen to
before
have you seen and you can get going
mm-hmm yeah
you know my my therapist would say i
think you feed into it a little bit i
think you're like
self-aware it's like here i go into my
darkness and this is kind of cool and
it's good to feel
dark and in so many words i don't think
i'm articulating it well
i understand what you're saying do you
do that i used to yeah and then i
realized it was super unhealthy
it is so now it's it's just like
like i said you you have to just have a
spot in you that you can go into
and it's it's easier you don't have to
sit in it for months
you know while you're shooting something
my uh therapist also said
you know what listen to mazzy star fade
into you and i go really she goes yeah
once don't listen to it five times
you're torturing yourself so that's why
i don't date actors
anymore why because they're just they're
too much
were you saying i'm too much yes yes
yeah
well we we dated yeah we did and we're
still good friends
we are that took it took a while it took
a little while but there was um
i think there's more there's an
understanding a very good understanding
that we have with each other now
it also wasn't you know it was it was it
was it was a time it was a nice time
we had some great times yeah i i just
moved to la
and you similar to when we were shooting
in vancouver
you were the first person to kind of
reach out and say i got you
and took me out on the town so yeah we
both had significant others at the time
i was dating someone you were dating
someone who was very
very just friendly and but again you
were a guest star and i was like
you know he's not a guester you season
seven you were
you didn't know how many times you were
going to recur
supergirl do you miss the conventions do
you miss going to cons
um i feel like the the thing i dislike
the most about conventions i'm still
doing which is traveling
[Music]
um but i do miss meeting the people i
miss like hanging out with you guys in
the green room and doing the panels and
shooting you with nerf guns in my eyes
you almost took out my eyes
eye i got your head and you had just had
neck surgery so i shouldn't have
i think you got me in the eye okay well
i'm sorry yeah i know you are
uh but other than that like i just did a
live
um signing we're starting to do these
live conventions on instagram i did it
yesterday and people buy the items on
stream lead
was it good yeah so streamley.com
hang on i got it oh yeah i'm sorry
picture picture picture streamly.com
slash lore of anavort
and you can buy your posters your 8x10s
i'm going to start selling
um some of the paintings people saw me
doing that they wanted to buy
we're going to sell some old scripts on
there but i'm going to do live signings
i'm going to schedule them like maybe
once a month
people really tune in and watch me sign
their items and then we send it
i miss cons i i i do i miss the people
i miss there's just this mutual respect
and love and
a great energy and you know it's nice
it's nice to go to these places
and you know see people that you've seen
before and there's you know their fans
and
but also you feed off of energy yeah
it's like that you're
extroverted for me it's like
i can do it but then i need recovery
time it drains
i enjoy it but look uh for me by the end
of these days
i'm absolutely spent and that's because
i give
so much of myself that within an hour
i'm like
hey what's going on how are you on my
game just i want everybody to feel
special
and at the end of the day you're just
you're wiped out if you do it well
if you do it the right way if you're
just sit there and sign and don't talk
to people and like
oh don't ask him that or don't he's not
going to do that why go to these
companies
who's your favorite actor you've worked
with that you really were like this
guy's a professional and just fun or a
girl or or
actor did i say what i said guy oh i
said guy he said actor and then this guy
that's fine what's the
actor um
actor's fine for both um i mean
elizabeth moss just blows me away
just because she's an ep and director
and the lead and i watched her like
seamlessly
flow between those roles and
and graciously and humble and and kind
so watching her was incredible um
and then joseph gordon love it i worked
with when i was younger and he blew me
away
really yeah what about ian summerholder
he's lovely
yeah he seems like a lovely guy uh he
was on smallville and he was uh
that guy's got a big following doesn't
he i don't know who that is
okay um vampire diaries
one of the guys you know the last time
we talked about
um that whole thing with um you know
the nexium yeah the whole she's going on
trial
i think this allison she is and i
remember we talked about that but we i
hadn't really
seen next thing the the show what was it
called
the vowel right about i hadn't seen it
were you blown away when you watched it
yeah i was how did you feel after
watching that
sad sad yeah sad for her
but also um hurt
that she came for me too so were you
close to doing it you think
i wasn't not i mean she invited me it
was that weekend i just couldn't afford
to do do you think you could have
gone through because when you watched
the first episode i i've said this
before in a podcast i was like
i'm in i'm in these people are
motivational they're here to help you
they're supportive it they
invite you in and if you're at all
vulnerable
you could easily slip inside this this
world
and think this is going to help me be
the best
i can be and unfortunately and i think
that's why everybody got into it and
then all this happens and it makes
you just question everything
you also wonder if while you're in it
you would re how quickly you would
realize
what it was yeah that's scary like it
took
them a while um yeah it
uh and i wasn't close with allison so i
i struggled with my feelings about it
because i had always wanted to get to
know her
when we were shooting yeah and then the
one time she did reach out to me years
after smallville was for that so it was
kind of a weird
what year it was for her god i just
moved to l.a because she she found out i
just moved so it's 2010
11 yeah i don't know and was it a big
cell
was it like a no it was a very soft cell
it like in terms of oh it's just
you know you come and join us and we'll
do we have books and it's a women's
group
and it's this much money and
you thought about it i thought about it
i also thought it sounded odd i was like
there's something weird
here because she's never talked to me
before you know
she really never talked to you on the
set she would in passing like we never
really had scenes together
she was pleasant to you but not overtly
yeah she didn't need to be we never
worked together i never spend time with
her which is why it was odd when she
reached out how did you feel about that
i think it was i was just in denial with
tom we were just like
nah i really didn't pay attention to it
for a while until it was in everyone's
face
around the news i mean you knew her well
so well i didn't know her
well i was on set with her we did scenes
together i directed her
um she was always sweet she was always
always knew her lines always gave her
100 percent uh it was a joy to work with
um you never think in a million years
that that would happen and you could you
go back though
you look back and you're like huh like
you saw that
she needed attention but i'm like okay i
need attention you need attention we all
need attention
but i don't know what she was i didn't
know her well enough because
it was obvious that she needed something
she needed something else and i don't
think it was what it ended up being
i think she just thought i need some i
want to be loved
i want to be in a group that i feel
comfortable she didn't go in i want to
be the best i can be
she didn't go in knowing of course not
so you can't fault her for that i think
she just got lost it's kind of like a
breakup in that
you think you know someone and then you
find out they cheated and then you go
back moment by moment trying to figure
out where things were
starting to unravel so for her when you
say you were going back
thinking about her on set over the years
it's it's that
it's the same thing yeah do you are your
parents the kind of
folks that give you a call after they
saw you in something say you were just
great we loved you do you get that from
both your mom and dad
um my dad communicates through my mom
i.e my mom
takes you know the electronic device and
texts me
my dad's not much of a texter so your
mom doesn't call you and say
we saw handmaid's take yeah she will
it's it's
oftentimes just like a whatsapp um and
then when i see her in person she'll say
it as well
oh so she does she gives she commends
you she they've been support like that
i started i was 12. i was with 12. they
she was
along the journey with me so for for her
now
she still wants to read scripts and i
send her them
i took this project you want to read it
yeah so you know she read and she reads
and she gives
she give any notes yeah she'll give
notes on things i write as well she
likes to
help correct grammar and your dad
doesn't get too involved
no my dad's my dad uh he's very
supportive they both are but my dad's
more stand off with that stuff i guess
what about when you
you know things like if you're what's
the word
unclothed or like for instance you did a
peta thing years ago
yeah we don't need to talk no but you
were like you know you did it because it
was you were trying to help raise money
for
for animals and things like that we get
it and you did it and it was just kind
of but was he bothered by like you know
i didn't like that you
weren't wearing these clothes or we just
didn't talk about it you never talked
about it
no my mom i don't know i don't know if
he ever saw it
they knew i was doing it my mom saw it
um
but no i never talked about it with him
yeah if there's projects that they want
to watch that i'm in and there's like an
inappropriate thing i'll just
say just be aware now if you ever had to
show your
bosoms this took a turn no it didn't if
you had
ever had to show like some if i had to
show my wang chung
you know if i had to show something ron
howard stern now would you would you no
we're not on howard stream would you i'm
just saying would you tell your parents
well yeah i would tell them
you would i would tell my mom who would
then eventually pass it on to my dad so
i don't have to directly tell him but
i also don't do those roles well i mean
look if somebody asked me if it was it
was spielberg had a role and he's like
listen we're gonna see your
schnitzel and you know and this is i
would probably say
hey mom and dad i don't want you to see
this movie because i really feel
uncomfortable if you saw
me my wiener because if there's one
thing that steven spielberg is known for
is that
asking his actors to shuffle and drop
trump buddy i'm just wondering how you
tell your parents like
for me i would be like oh my god i want
them to see this yeah you just tell them
don't don't watch it even if it's a
little provocative like i've had some
sex scenes
in smallville that i i think got a
little heated i don't know if they cut
but i remember saying don't watch this
episode
right not that they did but i
but i felt uncomfortable i feel kind of
you know my my family's kind of weird
like that
i don't feel comfortable kissing someone
in front of them of course i would have
a cigarette in front of my parents
maybe my mom right do your parents do
you smoke in front of your parents you
vape do they know you vape
they know i vape are you trying to stop
that yes it's bad
it is but it's better than smoking some
would say i don't know yes
inside of you is brought to you by 10
000 i don't know about you guys but when
i'm working out or if i'm going for a
run or whatever i'm doing i've got to be
comfortable and
thank the lord for ten thousand they've
got these seven inch interval
shorts with the liners they're
lightweight
shirts it's
ryan it's so incredibly comfortable and
i'm not chafed
tons of features for 10 000 like silver
ion for odor protection breathable and
lightweight shell fabric with stretch
optional liner that is very comfortable
and as i said prevents chafing
perfect summer shirt lightweight
breathable and quick
drying 10 000 makes the highest quality
best fitting
and most comfortable training shorts in
the world according to me
at the core of 10 000 are three core
training shorts built for all the ways
you
train the interval short versatile and
great for hiit
spinning metcons short runs and anything
else you can think of
the foundation short built for
durability for tough gym days and
outdoor adventures
the session short super lightweight
perfect for running
yoga and mobility 10 000 is a direct
to consumer company no middleman so you
get premium fabrics trims and techniques
that other brands
simply cannot afford collaborative
product development a team of over
actually 200
athletes tests their gear to ensure the
perfect design
fabric trims and fit i want athletes to
design this
i want them to go through this to see if
these are worthy and they do
and that's pretty cool pick the short
that's best for your training and then
personalize it with custom liner and
inseam options over 9500
five-star reviews free shipping and
returns lifetime guarantee
10 000. 10 000 is offering our listeners
15 off your purchase you just go to 10
000. cc and enter code inside to receive
off your purchase that's 10 thousand dot
cc
and enter code inside inside of you is
brought to you by
got pet products guys you know how much
i love got
shout out to my big bro adam part of
this operation
uh just a wonderful wonderful product my
doggy blanche
loves got products the family behind
charlie bear is also behind a human
ingredient company that has been
bringing
expertise creative imagination and a
passion for food to people for more
than a century charlie bear treats are
unbelievable
blanche can't get enough of them your
dog will too if you're
feeding yourself top-notch food if
you're treating yourself to
really healthy meals good meals the best
food for you
why wouldn't you do that for your animal
it just makes no sense
your dog or your cat should be eating
top
grade products the charlie bear treat
they're natural dog treats from our
family to your best friend
they're made in the usa they're simple
natural ingredients low calorie
many charlie bear treats only have three
calories each
pocket friendly will not crumble and
make a mess in your pocket
wallet friendly high value rewards and
most importantly your dog
will absolutely love them look for
charlie bear products at your favorite
neighborhood pet stores and online or
visit our website at www.charliebear.com
that's
c-h-a-r-l-e-e-b-e-a-r
dot com charliebear.com and you can also
get their amazing food that blanche
loves as well
there's so many flavors of hound and
gatosk
so if you want to learn more about the
food that blanche is eating just go to
www.houndhound.gatisgatos.com
i love this product this is what my dog
eats and i hope it will
be what your dog eats too give them a
shot
but let's talk about uh let's talk about
covid and the pandemic and how you did
as
an extroverted person who likes to have
friends around all the time was that
really tough for you i was thinking
about that you know what i did i ordered
a ton of food from the grocery store
i loaded up the refrigerator and i took
pictures of the refrigerator of all the
food that was in there
and i ate a lot and i cooked a lot why
did you take pictures of it
because i just loved having a stocked
fridge it just looked
so it was just for personal yeah i just
was like wow look at this so like you'd
lay in bed at night and scroll through
your photos
i got root beer and i got sprite and i
got
you know i've got like all these lined
up cans it was like a concession stand
it was just like
all these chips and i had oranges
grapefruits lemons i had
so much good stuff in there that i just
wanted to
take a picture of all the great stuff i
had that doesn't answer the question
i'm thinking of what i did i watched a
lot of movies
what you did i'm asking how you doing i
struggled
i struggled i struggled like a lot of
people and a lot of people struggled way
more than i did but i definitely
struggled for my mental health it wasn't
great
it wasn't great now conversing with
people not uh hanging out with people
but i did have my friend rob who
uh or he had covet early on so
once he got through that i felt safe
with him and we started recording a lot
of music
yep and playing music and that saved me
that was my savior and a lot of darkness
and things
it was very cathartic to to write you
know the album for sun spin
um i don't know if you heard the album
yet no but you should i think you'd like
it i
we worked hard on it i know i mean i
know a lot happened to you during
covet yeah well i lost my grandfather
but he was right before kovitz started
so i lost irv in
on thanksgiving right the november
before so just months before that
the last thing i did was i went with tom
welling to mexico to sign autographs
and that's when they were starting to
like wear masks don't wear masks wear
masks don't wear masks rosenbaum why
aren't you wearing a mask
it was kind of like nobody knew what the
hell was going on they're going to lock
down la i left a day early from mexico
boom jet it jet at home and next thing i
know
i am in my home for a week and then i go
oh this is going to be done and remember
the conversations every day you'd have
conversations
oh yeah we'll be done with this in a
month mm-hmm oh yeah
two months oh my god and then my grandma
calling me and crying and i miss my my
irvy and then me it was an emotional
work it was a lot it was a lot and i
haven't um
you still talking to a therapist um i do
i need to see one more but i see
i see my therapist and um
you know i get lost i get lost
sometimes and i feel like you just can't
be helped and then i feel like
you're an idiot of course you could be
helped this is exactly
the mentality that you cannot have that
when you're talking to people on the
podcast and you're like you know you can
get through this this is well the only
life we get
it is true man it's like as far as we
know this is it we have to do whatever
it takes
and if you don't take a step forward if
you don't take a walk if you don't take
a little hike if you don't go play with
your dog if you don't do things that
make you happy make you smile if you
don't do these things
yes you are going to go down a black
hole you are going to a downward spiral
and there's no getting you out of it
unless you take that first step
and so i do that man i i find myself
down
low and then one thing will trigger a
response i'll go wow i did that and i
felt good
well why don't you do it again yeah and
that's what i do did you
how how were you um i so i was
helping my sister with her kids but uh
then i went and did a project and had
in vancouver or no in ontario we were
the first production back in ontario
like a month or whatever it is four
months in to the pandemic
and uh so i had to rent an apartment so
i was separate from her and the kids and
my first quarantine of 14 days this will
i saw that this will be my fourth
quarantine going back because canada's
still in lockdown
so my first quarantine of 14 days was in
a small apartment
on the 20th floor in the winter i was
super depressed
um and that's when i wrote my first film
so
you i just was i just leaned into it and
you did the work it was what you did
yeah you knew that this is what i have
to do i have to create something or this
is going to get bad
get worse get worse yeah well i'm super
proud of you
if it means anything i i really always
want to see you thrive
i always want to see you happy thank you
and it just makes me
it really makes me happy when i hear
that you're doing nice things and you're
taking care of yourself
um it's time for talking with laura
vandervor these are fan
questions my from my lovely patreon if
you want to join patreon patreon.com
inside of you i'll message you after and
uh it's a wonderful family and
and check it out patreon.com inside you
this is from
colima g which one would you rather have
the ability to understand and talk to
animals
or the ability to speak and understand
all languages animals
i think the ability to speak and
understand all languages i gotta go with
that one ryan
i might have to go languages too
wouldn't it be great to just go to like
we're going to
uh give me the the bangkok
or what's what's uh suburbia not
suburbia
serbia suburbia as a movie what
languages do you think you're going to
like told you i'm strangers don't speak
english yet
no no it's what's that big frozen
country norway
no it's it's not even it's part of
russia
oh uh siberia siberia to go to siberians
just start talking to someone
or be in like vietnam or be it just to
be able to understand
everybody that's the key to happiness in
this world man if we could just
understand
communication too communication but also
how great would it be to be able to talk
to your dog
i do every day yeah but to actually want
to go to doggy park
she would go crazy you should go with me
to doggy park leanne p
fondest memory of your time on
smallville
i want to say my first time in the
harness flying
really yeah and then on like that was by
myself
um there was a moment where they have me
on the water tower and i stand up and i
do like the supergirl thing and
i felt pretty cool um otherwise it was
probably when
[Music]
tom was directing and you i had to get
shot that whole thing was
quite an experience for me oh yeah or
were you directing no tomorrow's
directing okay he got a reaction out of
you yeah
but he didn't tell you and he was like
bam you're like holy yeah he scared
the on me he did
he did a couple times tom you're a prick
kelly s
this is well i don't know why i'm
reading this one while working on the
set of small did you have any conflicts
or issues with michael
don't be a smart ass no although i did
think you were really charming and and
sweet and cute
is that a conflict well it was conflict
for me oh
it was complete i remember the day you
brought your girlfriend to set and my
boyfriend was
on set we're all like hey it was just
like you can be attracted to other
people it's healthy to be in a
relationship be attracted to other
people that's just
that's life man yeah matt w was your
spaceship on smallville cgi or did they
actually build it out of foam or
something like that my spaceship did i
have a speaker i don't know i'm not the
questions for you i didn't i don't think
i had a spaceship unless i'm forgetting
so isn't there a ship in some
barn or some factory
i'm going to say cgi cgi and and if we
were
if we had scenes in it it was a
practical i would do remember a scene
with allison and something mechanical
right it might have been a ship was it
tangible was it real can you touch it
yeah okay little lisa what's been your
most memorable moment at a con
oh probably um
this is just something i heard at a
convention
the the seats were filling up for one of
our panels i don't know if you were
there
heard this and i guess two people were
fighting over
a seat and someone took their pen out
and poked the other guy in the eye
like pocket protector pen got him in the
eye just to get the seat
do they kick him out of that that's not
my favorite moment that's just a
memorable one
that's an intense moment on the that's
my
seat i'm here to see cara cara right uh
cara cara um i'm sure i have more
memorable ones usually it's just like
green room stuff though
jeremy c i i already answered this or
she answered this who is your favorite
actor actress to work with and she said
elizabeth moss
mm-hmm so there you go what about you
i've had so many people that i thought
were great to work with i just remember
clint eastwood as a director was
so sweet made me feel so good midnight
in the garden of good and evil i just
remember he goes
you know i had to cry in this one thing
and you know they end up cutting that
scene but i remember
he it was my first moment spacey's there
and
john cusack's there and i have to cry
and it's after this
courtroom scene and i'm sitting there
and i'm just listening to fleetwood mac
and my headphones trying to
good choice think of like you know
something sad
and my grandma and he comes over and he
sits next to me and he just kind of puts
his hands on his face and he goes
pretends he's crying he's like oh gosh
i'm like uh what are you doing clint
and he goes well i'm just trying to make
you loosen up a little bit
and i kind of smiled and he goes oh jess
we've got all day just let this happen
naturally just
you know when you're ready you let me
know oh it's gonna be great
it's amazing and he got up and he walked
away and i kind of just from there got
the
confidence and i remember looking at him
about a minute later and he was behind
the camera and
he gives me a thumbs up he goes and i go
thumbs up there was no action said he
looked at his dp
said jack and he did that little rolling
sound with his finger
and all of a sudden everything started
to go in place the lights the this the
camera
everybody was where they needed to be
where they had to be
and we went in and he pushed in on me
pushed on me goes
all right well how'd that feel
and i go well how do how did you feel
and he goes well it felt great to me
and i go does he want another one i go
okay he did one more and like in the
he was just so sweet he goes michael
that was fantastic on the next take away
to
recognize the jury a little bit like in
the courtroom scene
just like little notes little things he
didn't come at me with it you know like
you got to do this you got to do this
one or two things gentle relaxed
atmosphere
i was at my best i think that's one of
my one of my better performances because
i was really relaxed and comfortable and
confident
that's the thing um that i've been
finding it's it's
obviously the environment of the set
it's it's the level of which the
director
talks to you but for me it's
it's someone checking in if you're okay
there's something triggering to that hey
you're okay yeah you're like oh god yeah
no i'm fine
and it immediately just like makes you
want to get emotional because someone's
checking in on you you know like if i do
a crying scene and then the director
comes over after and he's like that was
great do you want another one and i'm
like
no i'm okay do you want water no i'm
fine are you okay as soon as they ask if
i'm okay
i ball you have to know what each actor
needs some actors
i don't need i don't want you near me i
don't need you i got this some actors
need a little love some actors need a
little
that's just who we are as humans we all
need different things i remember allison
on
smallville i was directing an episode i
remember she came up and she had to cry
in the scene
and she goes michael he just and we're
about to roll
hold me or no no she just said will you
tell me that story about your
grandmother
but my grandmother ruthie passed and i
started to tell her the story and all of
a sudden her eyes just went
watery and i go let's go roll cameras at
you know in action and
and it just was like a really nice
moment lisa h i absolutely
loved you in the remake of v i think the
dynamic of your character
the dynamic your character was so
dynamic it was so interesting what was
your favorite memory of working on that
show and did you feel the cancellation
of it was premature
and that was from who uh that was from
lisa h hello
lisa h um thank you
v was an interesting beast because um
my character lisa basically
was a lizard um in human skin
so i wasn't allowed to emote very much
which was interesting everything had to
be
very calculated and subtle
um i had a lot of fun playing the role i
do think it was
it ended too soon we had a great
following it was abc people were loving
it but i just think
you know they didn't know where to take
it the producers weren't communicating
we got a call we got three calls in one
day
hey we're getting we're just gonna be a
mini series hey we're
gonna get another season hey we just got
canceled and there was like hours apart
so they
no one knew what was happening and we
still don't know why it was were you
heartbroken
cancelled uh at the time you know cause
i was like this is
probably gonna be my last job we always
think that yeah tom
and what's your favorite prop you kept
from tvs or movies
i no longer have it because i sold
everything off to fund my film
um i did yeah what was the biggest
seller my kryptonian bracelet
how much can't remember a thousand
i think it was like two but i'd have to
check it maybe i should sell my lex
luther it's actually a uh
it's the trench coat that i wore when i
was zod yeah i still
built for me i wonder if i sold that for
charity i could i could do one of my
charities and give it to charity that'd
be great
i sold off our crew warm-up jacket that
said smallville season seven
anything that i could do to create this
film that i wanted to i was like willing
to part with that stuff
although i'm i'm fairly sad about it but
um what are you looking for for the
for the in in the future then
what do you what do you want like what
do you do you want to just continue
working i mean obviously you want a
family
you still want a family and all that
stuff you don't need to get into that
but
i mean what makes you happy what makes
you what gives you
joy
family brings me joy um
that's such a loaded question it is it's
a tough one it wasn't a really good one
either
no it wasn't very good mm-hmm wasn't my
best no we're used to that though it's
okay
um yeah that's a tough one i think i'm
i'm i'm
i'm going towards the things that bring
me joy right now
so i can be i can swim in it rather than
visit it
i think your gut reaction when you said
family i think boom yeah that was it
i think that's where you guys my family
like the potential of my own potentially
your own family yeah
when you work and work and work and like
i need work i'm never gonna stop working
that's a passion
right i think when you care about
someone else and you take care of
someone else like a child
and they become the center of attention
and you're not the center of attention
anymore
i think that will become something
special for for anyone who has a kid i
assume that's
i think my mother loved us but my mother
was still she was
young when she had all of us and she was
always the center of attention and that
that's not you have to give that up i
don't like being the center of attention
anyway
i like taking care of people and things
you know that's
my dog is things like my dog
yeah um so i don't think that would be a
rough transition for me i think more so
it's like trying to find
where to how to separate the focus
because when i work i'm all in
right so it's finding the balance well
this has been easy and fun wasn't it
are we done i think so i mean what was
your uh what's your handle so people
could follow you
uh on instagram it's super vandy
although guys i'm trying to get my name
so if you can help me i don't know how
to do that someone has it
either someone has laura vandervor
someone has laura van der voort someone
has the laura van divorder
and it won't fit on on twitter that's
why mine's the
mine's michael rosen bum i couldn't fit
an a in there so i had to put bum
on twitter it's appropriate though thank
you you show that often
thank you and twitter is bandykins22
there you go
anything uh you want to say that's
coming out you just worked on this film
i just worked on this film
um my the the film i've just directed
will be
hopefully getting into festivals what's
that called upcoming year my soul to
take myself to take
uh our instagram for that is my soul to
take film follow it guys
check it out she's worked very hard she
sold all her smallville memorabilia to
make it
oh sad day bad day but i made a film so
it's all worth it it's all worth it your
dreams are coming true
yes well i hope the rest of your dreams
come true thank you you too
and uh you can do this yeah i i think
you know we can do it right indy
it's indiana jones if you're watching if
not you don't know what i'm talking
about
uh laura thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you this was awesome i
i love that it's live it's you're here
with me it's different isn't it ryan
do you find it awkward yeah i'm not i'm
not ready
oh my god touch him uh laura just
touched ryan everything's just going out
of control i'm going back to canada and
lockdown and i can't be near anyone
so this is this is the most i'll get so
thank you well guys this was a pleasure
it was fun it's always having
always a good time hopefully every
couple of years you'll come back yeah
anytime i'm in la if it's not too soon
we'll do it again
all right we'll see you
uh i thought laura was really good today
i thought she uh you know she
you think she's not gonna say much you
think she's not gonna
tell it how it is but she she can't help
herself she's like me she's just gonna
if she doesn't like something she says
it if something happens she kind of
insinuates
i like having her on the show i want to
have her on the show as you know at
least
you know once a year or something like
that there's a few guests that i like to
have on like the stephen amells the tom
wellings the
maybe the kristen crooks the old the old
gang from smallville
erica um but and i also appreciate you
guys always
chiming in saying you should get this
guest it's not that i don't listen it's
that i try and
a lot of times i fail remember i get 99
of my guests i email them or i get their
email from someone and then i message
them like kenan thompson from snl
hey keenan you don't know me but you
worked with my friend so and so and i
was just wondering if you did hello
hello but uh yeah
you didn't get keenan thompson is what
you're saying no not yet but i'm gonna
keep trying i love him i think he's
hilarious
isn't he funny that'd be great it'd be
great yeah that would make my day i'm
trying for keenan i'm trying for
i've tried for jack black i've tried for
people but uh anyway it was a good
episode and i really appreciate laura
again if you want to join patreon
patreon.com inside of you
uh also any merch on the inside of your
online store
um and sunspin.com for any band merch
why don't we read the names off
let's do it these are my lovely patrons
top tier patrons who get back to the
show in more ways than one
nancy d barry no mary
mary f no mary b harry b leah you threw
me
uh s trisha f sarah v
little lisa u kiko jill e brian
h lauren g nico p robin
s jerry w robert b jason
w a puff theon kristen
k amelia oh allison l lucas
m raj c you had got the whole first page
i don't know if you could do anymore
joshua d emily s
cj p samantha m
jennifer p and you're right jennifer and
jackie
p stacy l carly
h carly i s
you that's got to be a record carly s
jen ass jamal f janelle b tablet 272 not
to be confused with 7273 ashley ryan
kimberly mikey l
on soprano 99 more ramirez san diego m
sarah f chad w leanne p
ray a maya p maddie s kendrick f ashley
e shannon d
matt w belinda n kevin v james r
chris h dave h samantha s spiderman
chase sheila g ray h
tabitha t tom and suzanne b
um these glasses really help i could
read better you look great
liliana a michelle k marcus w hannah b
michael s talia m andrew t betsy d
claire m
liz j laura l chad l rochelle
nathan e taylor k marion s
meg k janelle p trev l dan
and diane r uh uh jetta
jetta lorraine g corey m veronica
okay yes big stevie w kendall
t t carol from down the street
d sandy b angel m eric
c rhiannon c stephen m cory k super sam
emily c
sherry s coleman g david c michelle a
matt w
liz l jeremy c andy t cody r
and chris e uh thanks that's the show uh
i hope you enjoyed it please subscribe
do all that you got to do spread the
word get people to listen
um you know it's we're in this love
together
we're in this love together there was a
song we're in this love
together i got the god and love forever
i was gonna say is it chicago no it's um
[Music]
we're in this love together i forgot
it doesn't matter maybe people bryson
not exactly sure
uh thanks for listening thanks for
watching thanks for subscribing
thanks for all that thanks for
everything you do i'm uh from the
hollywood hills in california
i'm michael rosenbaum i am ryan diaz
ryan give a little wave
we love you guys thank you for allowing
me to be inside of each and every one of
you i wish you a glorious week i hope
you're uh healthy and happy and
safe and uh taking care of yourself
trying to love yourself a little more
and trying to love the world man try to
love love people in general
my brothers i mean i think it's
important man people are just
nasty to each other aren't they can we
just be nicer i try to be nicer to
people
i've said enough i'm done